what's up babes and buds i'm hitting the
road i want you to come see me in
december i'll be uh the fourth and fifth
the west palm beach improv december 10th
in boston at the chevrolet theater
that's gonna be a big one boston you
always come out hard i can't wait to see
you guys this is a big one for me
atlantic city saturday december 11th
that's basically a local show for me
i've never played ac can't wait for all
my friends and family will be there come
see my dad and everyone that's been on
the show he's so excited for it uh and
then the week of december 26 through
december 31st come see me and kristy d
co-headline we're going to be at dallas
houston san antonio st louis columbus
and then new year's eve we are partying
in cincinnati the pimp will be there
we'll all be there all tickets on sale
right now at
savilecountercomedy.com and
15 more cities are going to be added for
january and february so please check out
salvocountercomedy.com for updates love
you
taste buzz they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them everything is gonna be good
is what sal
just said to me taste buddies
how are you all welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buds
uh bit of a stressful day yeah yeah for
me yeah well you're going through you to
be expected
tbe yes you're opening
a bar
tb sandwich shop bar and i've got bde
bde big dick energy okay okay right
i don't know what does that mean that
you're like you worked out no i was just
cause you said tbd okay no way
tbe expected which i made up do you not
know big dick energy no i i didn't i
never really i don't have it memory as
bde you know it didn't pick that up
somebody texted that to me today that's
why it was in my head and then you just
said the other what is it just like when
you when you just cool or something like
that or yeah like you you walk around
like you got a big dick okay yeah which
i don't but what does that constitute i
don't walk around i don't have
or walk around like i have no no uh
i don't think at least meanwhile the
business you're opening is is is a is a
double entendre of a penis joke
no heart eight yeah joey roses yeah no
heart ate his craps what it's craps
oh sure no that's what we we needed
after craps well eight sandwiches for
eight dollars it's the hard eight it's
like the double fours when you get the
double fours yeah i never picked up on
that that's really naming it after a
penis joke
no did you no jesus i said this to you
on air to your face once i i quipped i
said this coming from a guy who names
his business after a penis joke
did i what did i say
you were saying explanation no you
didn't you know i never heard that
explanation until this second and
where is my mind that i've never even
attached it to crap but now you have me
on that i don't know if i can unsee it
right it is tough to unsee yeah come and
get the heart eighth
i mean it is provocative it was
unintentionally provocative i didn't
realize
you know what's funny i didn't realize
it sounded like that
which is funny because you're saying how
could you have missed the craps
reference
i never
thought it sounded perverted until i did
seth herzog's podcast and he said what
is the handle so i can plug it and i
said it says joey rose's heart eight and
he goes that's perverse and i was like
no it's i'll wait i guess it does happen
i didn't realize it yeah
anyway but you're putting the bar
together and you you're it's culminating
because it's
maybe by the time this airs it will have
opened i hope so yeah
you're you're a week out from your
opening two weeks maybe so we shoot this
a little yeah behind you yeah yeah
you're seeing this we should be open
when you're seeing this
um
but
come down no no wait
wait a minute when does this episode
drop pimp
um i don't know in the future yeah
because
in the year 2000.
do you know that reference i love conan
okay but this is not our thanksgiving
app hold i'll tell you right now no
uh reese's did reese's there yet
he did so the next step is halloween kid
versus halloween adult and then we did
two
first
and then we did november 18th and 15th
this is slated to air november 22nd this
is thanksgiving
hi
you have a lot to give thanks for hold
on let me look up the account i'll tell
you holy [ __ ]
man we didn't do any of the [ __ ] we said
we were going to do for the holidays
november 22nd boo
yeah so
if i hope the bar better be open by the
time you're saying this or it means
even more [ __ ]
has become
just so that they understand at home
right now it's june 2017. yes yeah
i just came up with the idea of opening
a bar
an hour ago
uh yeah this it should be open and
hopefully uh pump and gas at this point
but uh but you know yeah you know but
it's but right now as we record this it
is not open it's approaching the opening
and it is very stressful
look at it look at that look at that
i'm not even doing that on purpose i was
just doing that like it's just
for those of you listening his hands are
trembling
well and it was clenched too oh clenched
cause when you showed me also
trembling and clenched double whammy big
bucks big bucks no whammy's end
stop stop stop
at four
what's the big thing to get on that
pressure luck pressure lock it's uh an
extra spin right that was the big thing
free spin yeah big bucks no way that was
all you wanted was free spin well you
wanted the money with the free spin on
it so you can keep going right oh
man i loved that show you want a little
trivia yeah do you know remember the
name of the host
wink martindale no that's another host i
know i know uh and it's a good guess if
you're taking a stab peter tamarkin
peter tamara peter tamarkin uh i have
trivia
do you know the name
of the dad
from blossom
okay
his real name or his real name
uh i can't place my favorite actor name
involved i can't place him ted wass
ted wass
i don't know why i love that dude
awesome yeah ted wass is the dad for
blossom or he's the other dad on my two
dads pimp can you can you can you riser
and the guy with the beard yeah ted
might be the dad
no no no just put ted wass at w-a-s-s
yeah dad from blossom ted wass great i
don't even remember his name
um uh but i was going to ask you about
uh blossom for a second now that you
touched on it yeah
is is that the one that goes in my
opinion nation yes the sun is gonna
surely
just one of the hundreds of awful randy
newman songs yeah what is opinionation
that's what randy newman does he says
like oh he makes that word like goofy
and
well i mean
he i i shouldn't say that's what he does
but like that's a very randy newman kind
of you know randy newman is i love him
l.a we love it yeah it's all his no i
know but but still i always say in my
opinion nation and i'm like am i saying
this right yeah yeah no it's just a word
he made up dumb word he made up
we can't play this on the pod though
right no no i definitely can't
oh is this the blast oh okay
yeah this was um
getting all depressed
blossoms look at look at joey lawrence
look at the look at this dancing look at
this dancing terrible blossom was the
opening to blossom i love that this kid
was clearly like i'm not dancing
[Laughter]
he's just like i'm not dancing every
other day
what what is this show about what is it
blossom it's about the coming of age of
a young girl from from from like about
tween to like 18.
and uh it's surprisingly edgier than you
think it is really what is that yeah
what is it yeah the brother has like a
is a recovering drug addict like a legit
recovering drug addict they get into
like the kids having like sex and stuff
like they're losing their virginity he's
heavy way heavier
versus punky brewster who you got
i'll take blossom that could be a battle
i'll take blossom all day no way i'll
take black punky bruce like whoa
punky brewster was so late moon fry
punky brewster was left outside a
shopping center by her father i'll take
blossom all day long no you're wrong
blossom's mom i'll battle you on that
[ __ ]
oh sorry jennifer
who's blossom's best friend because i
thought she was uh gibbler six six six
right no
gibbler yeah that's another good battle
uh i i would definitely do blossom
versus punky brewster they just rebooted
punky brewster and blossom is still on
tv
punky brewster yeah she's going to play
pokemon i've never heard her she's like
the mom now she's like a mom with kids
she's
she's
she's posting totally right isn't it
it's a adult punky brewster yeah it's a
sequel series where she's grown up now
and like she's got my balls are blown
off
when does it start what's the network
what's the streaming platform babe it
came and went it was on people it
already happened yeah yeah yeah and she
they call it punky as a mom
no it's called punky brewster right but
she was punky brewster
no i know she's punky brewster as a mom
in the show they were like hey punky oh
i thought you were asking if the show
was called punky as a mob no the show's
just called punky brewster i'm saying is
she referred to as punky she's right
there
she's smoking hot too she's a real cute
shout out to a little bit from the style
look she's still wearing the overalls
oh yeah soleil roon fried very very sexy
vibes
what do you look what's man i got a gnat
in here um
isn't that the girl from full house
i am on board i'm gonna watch this
maybe because at the full house came out
they were like no that's not her that
she kind of looked like a daughter from
full house it's not the same actor
so yeah so the first time uh what's the
name walked on jody sweden is that a
name
that's when he's working on the new one
i made a nice a nice on the fly quip
there i went whoa more like full blouse
it was just waiting
it was a discernible difference enormous
fake breath
yeah yeah i saw her god bless i was at a
party i was at a party at the house of
the guy who created full house
all right
when i lived it out full house party
yeah and you can imagine this man has
quite a house he's made quite a bit of
money in his time wow but i was at a
party at his house and the entire crew
was there saggit stamos do you know
saggit i know sag it a little bit like
to say hello or whatever but the whole
crew was there saggit stamos
cut it out
younger sister
no olsons weren't there no cut it out
cool
i believe coulier was there uh and then
the two main the main two daughters
cameron cameron
cameron uh
kirk cameron yeah uh
candace cameron yeah they were both
there um wow but yeah she
our bosom looks considerably smaller
here in this interview well they're
shooting them flat they're shooting at
flat long lens
it just was uh you know jarring i
remember seeing her and being like
i remember
finding her extremely attractive who
jody sweden in real in like real life is
adult
yeah oh oh yeah i was there two years
ago oh oh oh i'm sitting at the party at
the party i'm saying she walked in and i
was like whoa like cool you know she's
like now were you the guy who shot shot
your [ __ ] like did you do a full house
bit to them
i didn't even talk to him okay i didn't
talk to any of them the one odd awkward
moment was
stamos you just kept pretty much
you know when you keep looking at
somebody because you can't stop
my eyes kept going
in the flesh my eyes kept going to
stamos and he did notice an adventure to
be honest
but i couldn't stop i just couldn't stop
glancing and play devil's ad for you
everybody's eyes go to stamos dude he is
gorge in real life he was he guess who
he's he's aging like a he's aging like a
whoo like a like a like a like a chemist
yeah dude he's gorgeous this was uh this
was a who's who he's over in the corner
with scott bakula
whoa quantum leap yeah quantum leaf
scott bakula i'm standing in a dude it
was it was it was uh it was the full
slate of programming it was uh
i'm in a corner i'm in a corner with
burr
and mike binder
star of mind of the hbo's mind of the
married man
it was oc man what what is going on at
this house party why is this house what
exactly is saggitt's birthday i believe
some of the beach boys were there they
performed at the house oh that's uncle
jesse's crew it was just wild
performs with that yeah norman lear was
there
i met norman lear i like i met norman
lear
norman lear i met him i sat and talked
to him for a little while he i mean he
must've been 90 years old he's old
he's alive still yet he's still alive
he's 99
he told okay this is a real story that
happened he told burr you spoke to
norman lear yes my favorite show of all
time is the jeffersons
i met the man wow my one of my top fives
is all in the family so it was wild but
he told burr at that party
because burr actually talked him for a
while i think they smoked a cigar
together or something and like burr said
at that party to him your body of work
is incredible like i mean it's just you
must look back on it and be so proud and
norman lear said i'm not done yet i'm
rebooting
uh one day at a time with a all
hispanic at the time it was hispanic
wasn't latinx yet
cast
and it was like a year later that that
netflix reaches latin next the new the
new i think show really i think so is
hispanic not right i mean i don't know
i'm hispanic i didn't know that i'm
trying to cover my oh that's right so i
can say whatever
because you could say whatever you want
i don't know
i was covering my tracks i got nervous
just now
in your mind you said it was a hispanic
cast i mean latinx right you said that
for my benefit no i said it because i
forgot that you were part
latinx yeah and i thought it was too
i've never called myself actually a
white man on a couch and i got nervous
that i was going to get cancelled no i'm
hispanic no no i'm your i'm your
hispanic robin quivers and then yes so
there you go exactly there you go
so uh
no but i i actually don't um
let it's latinx instead of latino
because
the x covers oh that's right
is it is that what it is so maybe i
don't even know this
i can't remember what he said but why is
it let's just say latinx used as a
gender neutral that's that's what i
thought okay okay
oh cause latino is male and the oh
in spanish the always masculine oh so
then maybe you still can't say hispanic
you just shouldn't say latino or but is
that how you pronounce it though pimp
can you hit that it is latinx yeah
latinx
all right take care
take it easy pronunciation guy latinx
well now i'm worried because i said it
wrong
god well latino you can't win this day
i'm gonna clip this part all right good
yeah yeah good perfect yeah
it's a good one you call it latinx which
doesn't make sense because it's not it's
not latino
it's latino so he's latinx he's right
yeah i'm saying i said it wrong
anyway
norman lear at that party told bill burr
about the one day at a time reboot that
dropped a year later which was kind of i
never even saw that come and go yeah
that was on netflix for like five years
dude this is a while ago this was about
six years ago i said two it was about
six years ago sing sing the opening i
got it already sing the opening sing
sing these songs one day at a time
couldn't
remember it if you had a gun to my head
really i was never a big one data time
fan this is it this is it yeah
actually i'm saying oh yeah no i don't
know i'm doing what you do and our days
will run on through one day at a time
one day at a time so hop on your feet
hop on your feet and then you don't know
what i don't remember you know what i
recently test me on any any 80s any 80s
sitcom test me i got you anything
i might not know every word but i'll get
the melody and i'll get some of the
words jeff foxworthy show i don't know
that empty nest
no i know empty nests i just love empty
nest
oh i know it's richard mulligan
finest uh and then i i could sing a dia
john right immediate immediately yeah
dear john
bobby
you read these lines shut here
i feel bad because i know i know but i
don't know if empty nest does emptiness
have lyrics it a hundred percent it has
lyrics i don't remember it but i promise
you with an empty nest
i think it might be i think that might
be instrument
i don't think so
well if you hit it i'll sing it
theme song lyrics
life goes on and so do we oh and how we
do it is no mystery
we we started it all as life goes on
one by one yes yeah you're good yes yes
you're good you
just need that little one um
taxi didn't have lyrics i don't know if
nothing when taxi came on when i was
little i wanted to just i wanted to kill
myself
it is the most depressed it's a sitcom
it came on like 11 30 syndicated and i'm
up as a kid and it's like
it's so silly
now here's the thing that is sad all the
way through the song
and it's to this day is sad
but
but
you know i bought a vinyl of i forget
the guy's name but he's one of the most
sampled
artists he's a jazz guy yeah i know he's
in the 70s one of the most sampled
hip-hop artists ever not heard not about
hancock no he's not a hip-hop he's like
the whitest dude on planet earth is he
the guy that did the golden girls no
okay but he's like the whitest dude on
planet earth he's a jazz pianist yeah
pianist and he is bob james bob james
has been sampled in hip hop 730 wow wow
um but anyway i bought the bob james
record of taxi coach benson and
when that theme kicks in it's like a
stone groove it's really awesome really
it's just the beginning it's very
misleading whereas mash all the way
through you want to jump off a [ __ ]
it was a stone groove my man exactly you
are the most righteous yeah just get the
[ __ ] out
shout out trading places yeah uh
stone groove all the time because of
that movie is that why you say it i love
that i said all this um
here's my two dads what was the other
one oh i love gary isn't gary shanley
also what's his name
brandi newman that's a patel this is no
gary no it's scary
yeah that's brandy newman i don't think
it is this is the theme to
gary gary called me up and asked if i
would ride his team so i think it's
randy i'm almost halfway finished how do
you like it so far how do you like
shining women give me the theme
uh i would need to hear it deep cut
deep
buddies
yeah dude it's the greatest i mean i did
the only one who threw down the gauntlet
they just took a billy joel yeah i mean
in my opinion nothing will ever top the
bosom buddies opening music how did that
show only my men who's my marriage my
man just passed away actually god bless
him god love him peter
no he didn't yeah he did squirrel yeah
he passed away this week wait what yeah
no he didn't i think he did but i hope
i'm not making a mistake i mean i hope i
am making a mistake oh where did he die
from man this week
uh
isn't that terrible
isn't that terrible oh that's so sad
yeah
i just love that show when i was younger
dude they should reboot bosom buddies
now
but it's like a trans show me and you oh
that's good right yeah or an odd couple
trends that'd be good yeah i watched
that
they should i think that's a good idea
well especially they're going to reboot
everything a matter of time what was the
premise i never seen they moved into
which one wasn't buddies was this you
could never do this now not meaning
because it's offensive just meaning
because it doesn't exist anymore but
there used to be hotel there should be
apartment buildings that were all same
sex
that was like a thing in the early 80s
in the
through the 80s actually
or heard of that but i just took it as
law from the show so they moved they
needed an apartment and they moved into
an all-female building so they have to
pretend they're women so they dress as
women to live in the building
and only two women in the building
uh marry joe sperber who's also past
wendy joe sperber excuse me who's also
passed away and donna dixon who plays
tom hanks's love interest dude uh know
of their secrets
we didn't we just go to this with donna
dixon donna dixon is someone famous his
wife
someone very famous is white i will tell
you like what i will tell you this
circa 83
there was nobody hotter than donna dixon
spouse right there dan aykroyd
oh really yeah yeah wait she's in
twilight oh that's straight she doesn't
just me and q one tell him steve dave
like like last month on and we were
talking about acroid and we connected it
to this and we're like holy [ __ ] well
they're still married dude she was
she was the hottest lady on television
in 83 i mean it was like you couldn't
you couldn't hold a candle donna dixon
uh suzanne summers was pretty buxom
suzanne summers but i'm talking shout
out joyce dewitt joyce dewitt
now joyce she deserves way more credit
if i had to pick i'm going dewitt yeah
dewitt in uh in the in the series reese
comp yeah yeah yeah i go do it too yeah
you go uh ropers or you go furley
i gotta tell you i love furley oh that's
because it's a good battle europa's
fairly although we are eliminating
people i love
books of buxom yeah plump especially
with lodge brush i would do
unboxing can you make can you make a
note of punky brewster versus blossom
and ropers versus furley
but i'll tell you this we might
want to go
if we're going to do sitcoms i don't
want to eliminate people from playing
all right well fair enough but i love
just saying i just want a note of it so
we don't forget but i'll tell you this
so a rapper just asked this it might
have been grandmaster kaz twitter asked
who are you
really and and i i responded to his
tweet and i said as much as i love
furley's coked out swinger energy he's
always sniffling which i'm convinced was
a real joke
uh oh a joke i i'm convinced it was a
good thing donna was just on that
i don't think he would i don't think
hillbilly no i think it was like don
knotts being like this is like a 70s guy
rolling around like yeah but anyway
i i love i i love roper dude
he's such
he's
pimp bleep it he's such a [ __ ]
he's
i mean there's just been he's one of the
great comedic
sitcom bad guy yeah like he's so
he hates his wife
he hates tripper greece company a girl
threesomes come everything how many
years was it on like seven seasons
something like that
can you believe and it's all on the
heels of of of uh john uh ritter god
that he's another
comedic genius i still can't believe
john ritter's gone i know right he
should still be alive today it's so cr
it's like what what happened with him
why do you pass like one of those like
it was like one of those weird like jim
henson things where it was like he
thought he had the flu it turned out it
was a rare lung infection that killed
him in two hours like it was like one of
those things
remember when what's-her-face died
uh
natasha liam neeson's wife
natasha uh
oh
from skiing remember from skiing yeah
from skiing
she skied and she hit like like oh she
died like sonny and cher natasha
richardson she she like fell when she
was skiing i didn't know that like she
thought she might have a concussion but
she felt fine and then she went like and
then she like just died because like her
brain was bleeding and she didn't know
it was crazy she thought that there
wasn't anything wrong like she was like
she thought she was fine
she had internal bleeding i didn't even
know this sonny bono hit a tree died on
impact i believe
that was a little different what a way
to go i mean right i i have hesitation
skiing since that happened
i got to tell you i skied as a kid
i've skied i'm professional i've skated
four times in my life i think
yeah i skied about six times when i was
a kid no good ng i am i was fine
whatever i was able to do it
the thought of doing that now is so
insane to me and so impossible
i can't even fathom how you could do it
i went to uh to vail
with uh sean patton steve renazi ari and
steve simone
and uh i didn't ski but i went for the
weekend we rented a condo and i took
lessons
and i and by the end of the day of
lessons i was really having a fun time
with it but i'm you're always in fear
but then you didn't ski the rest of the
time
i was there like two three nights i
skied one day on my own i think and then
one day with lessons oh oh i thought
you're saying you didn't ski the whole
time you were there
i said i didn't ski
i i didn't i haven't prior to that yeah
oh okay yeah now i got it did those guys
all ski they all ski they were doing
like jumps
not steve steve simone didn't ski once
he stayed in a condo
me and see watch tv and just like hung
out a lot that's great that's great but
um i could for some reason i picture
patton patton's got a real belushi vibe
like i picture him being very nimble
on the skis and you know yeah i don't
really know because i didn't go with
them because they were such higher
levels than me
yeah ari i'm sure has probably skied the
actual alps on one of his goofy
excursions out of town but uh ever tell
you my first ski trip i vomited all of
my friend baze
i think i told it on a podcast it was a
class trip i was a freshman and it was
freshmen and seniors from our school and
a girls school and we met at school at
like six in the morning and it went up
to
bear mountain or whatever the hell it
was and i didn't eat and i used to get a
car sick as a kid and me and my friend
was sitting in a in a up in the front at
two chairs together he was wearing an
all white sweatsuit
and he was sitting at the window i was
sitting at the aisle and all the seniors
and older kids were up hanging out in
the aisle like talking there's a
bathroom in the back of the bus
and i started to get carsick and then
there was a point where i thought i was
going to throw up and i it was this was
like the first month of school this is
my friend from the neighborhood so we
just happened to go to school we knew
each other so we said let's do it i said
i have to get up i get to get make my
way to this bathroom i'm gonna throw up
i mean i'm a freshman in school all the
girls are there seniors and everything
and i'm like excuse me excuse me i'm
trying to get through and everyone's
talking so loud and they're in the
aisles and they're not moving and i made
it about a third of the way maybe half
and i said dear god i'm not gonna make
it to the bathroom time and i'm gonna
throw up really i didn't know what to do
i about faced i said i'll just go
throw up somebody under my seat and i
went and i wasn't gonna make it i turned
i got all the way back to the front i
passed everybody i got back to my seat i
turned and he was sitting at the window
and i just went
and it shot out like the exorcist and
just coated his entire body in his white
sweatsuit i feel so bad to this day it
was what 30 years ago the face he made
was a face i feel like you make like
right before you die he was he recoiled
in absolute horror
and then he smelled like vom for the
rest of the trip up there this was in
the morning then we went there went
skiing that's really good he was known
as the kid that threw up on himself all
day and i felt bad about that that's
really gross yeah and that's really
really gross
i remember i dated a girl and the first
time she ever stayed at my place i don't
even think we had even made out yet
it was like right before we started
dating
but she slept at my place and we were
kind of flirting i don't know it's weird
but anyway sounds like fun she woke up
in my bed and she was in the middle of
the night and i looked over and she was
covering her mouth and folding puke into
her mouth and she had to run into the
bathroom god bless her she didn't she
didn't spill a drop
and then she was really mortified um
which
you know it's disgusting but you know
you cannot be mortified if it happens to
you
i was like don't worry about it you know
i didn't go near for a couple days but
you haven't you ever
you ever had that thing where you're
standing at a bar anything else wrong so
you just put your head under the bar and
just throw up right at the bar
wow jesus christ
in your life what happened twice always
like you do a shot and you're like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] place is packing like and
you just duck under and throw up on the
floor wow i have always gonna remember
yeah that's really i you don't want to
do it you have no choice i have always
been able to get to the toilet in time i
know when it's coming i sense it i mean
i'm talking about this has got to be
again like 25 well yeah yeah but i'm
saying even as a kid i think as a kid
once when i had a bad flu i didn't make
it to the bathroom i just i was running
to the bathroom and i puked but like
even in my earliest days of drunks like
i just ne i always knew enough to get to
get to a bathroom
to get outside i was always able to hold
it long enough what about vom in school
glad i didn't do it but they just it's
just it's so mortifying that person gets
shunned
they have a scarlet v they get out of
the room then then a janitor comes 40
minutes late and throws some wood chips
on it dude remember the stuff that
smelled like cheese they would cover it
with no disgusting they would put the
stuff over vomit in my school and it had
like it it made it it gave it a cheese
smell like a cheese bait oh it was
disgusting it was it was disgusting the
uh we gotta get to the battle i think
yeah jesus yeah we really wasted a lot
of half hour oh jesus all right all
right sorry guys we're just you know
we're talking here
lots of action some vomit talk why not
yeah let's go to food mostly food
podcasts
speaking of taco bell no i'm kidding
all right taste buddies let's talk about
light stream okay the holidays are
approaching you may be thinking about
how you're going to save some extra
money well we have got a solution that
maybe you haven't thought of consolidate
your high interest credit card balances
to a lower rate and save with live
streaming livestream offers credit card
consolidation loans with rates starting
at just 4.98 percent uh that's a pretty
low apr with auto pay and excellent
credit you can get that rate that's much
lower than the national average interest
on credit cards which is usually uh you
know 19 right that's wild something like
that plus your rate is fixed so rates
continue to rise you won't your rate
when it starts that whatever rate you
get it's not budging is the point you
know so there are no fees uh your rate
never goes up you can even get your
money as soon as the the same day that
you applied for this thing which is
pretty crazy uh livestream believes that
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience and that's exactly what
they deliver so just for our listeners
the taste buddies they apply now to get
a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get the
discount if you need to get some money
is to go to lightstream.com taste buds
you probably could have guessed that but
let's talk about it again l i g h t s t
r e a m light stream dot com slash taste
buds
subject to credit approval rates range
from four point nine eight percent apr
to 19.99
apr and include a 0.50 auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
that's no surprise terms and conditions
apply and offer the subject to change
without notice visit livestream.com
tastebuds for more information as the
weather cools whoa
you know
one of your favorite materials returns
to the foreground as our hero material
offering comfort coziness and the
weightlessness to keep you going on your
feet all day long
all right i hear what i'm saying well
let's tell them what we're talking about
well we're talking about the benefits of
all birds wool
runners uh these are shoes okay
all birds encouraging listeners like you
to go and check out their original style
check out what these guys are doing
we are settling into the fall season
life is picking up again we know what's
coming for us these days staying
comfortable it's at the top of your list
okay you want to be warm but you want to
be comfortable you're going to lace up
this pair of all birds wool runners and
you're going to see that all birds has
redefined what it means to be
comfortable all day long
made from soft sustainable merino wool
the wool runners don't just feel good
they look good too i have a three pair
three yeah i have a pair that i had
before they were ever a sponsor
and i bought my dad a pair and now since
they became a sponsor i ordered another
pair yeah they're they're made uh really
uh also i think it's this should touch
on this but they are made sustainably
which they we will touch on which i
thought was really cool then i threw
them on and dude they are like
one of the most comfortable pairs of
shoes i own i love it they're made with
soft itch-free
uh materials and they're naturally
durable uh they're zq certified merino
wool uh they're the most sustainable
wool that you can get with that that zq
certain i don't i knew very little about
zq merino wool until all birds came i
this is the most sustainable of all
walls they are simple too i like that
they go with anything they're simple
stylish you get like one full color uh
proving that comfort design and
sustainability don't have to be mutually
exclusive you can machine wash them easy
to wear easy to clean and they're a
great shoe to wear with almost any
outfit they look classic you know
especially with a pant like this a
jogger pant yeah this is what i was
getting out of actually before all birds
is a carbon neutral company thanks to
sustainable practices like using natural
materials and perching purchasing carbon
offsets uh
yeah they know we can create a more
sustainable future together but only if
we hold ourselves accountable to tread
lighter on the planet so start off the
season right with a pair of wool runners
from alberts find your own pair of wool
runners at
allbirds.allbirds.com today okay so it's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s dot com check them out
so it's kfc taco bell today i'm taking
ksc i'm taking taco bell now i'm gonna
say this right out of the gate kfc is my
most frequented fast food place i love
kfc i've made it very clear on the show
how much i love kfc and fried chicken i
did not take fried chicken in the fried
chicken battle why because i also love
barbecued spare ribs and i thought i
could defend them i lost
i am taking taco bell in this battle why
because i also love
taco bell and i feel that i can defend
it
so i'm just saying this out loud for
anybody going louie
[Laughter]
[Music]
you are to our hearing impaired audience
love caves
no no that's don't make that joke that
you sound like you were hearing a pet
don't make that joke hey make that joke
they can't hear you
no i'm i'm telling you that's what you
sounded like i could have went somewhere
else with that but i didn't no one of
you sounded like i just sounded like you
know what you worked in you worked with
explosives your whole life
and now you're an older man
and that's how you talk at home kids it
sounds like i could have been insulting
what groups of people types of groups
different groups i know what you meant
you meant but i was no derozan but you
started going through it
i was doing the annoying guy yeah i was
doing this one fan did right how long
till derosa calls taco bell mexican
mcdonald's
oh that's beautiful
my uh
my my girl always does that when she's
talking to me and when she's she does a
version of me
you told me yourself you were like i'm
not gonna do that yeah yeah and i'm like
what is what is this voice i don't do
this voice that's not my voice why are
you paroding back to me a person i've
never met before it's what she's what
she hears i think right i think she
thinks i'm just some just terrible big
oath it's what you sound like to
[Music]
i would love to witness that i would
love to witness that so kfc i i i was
taco bell i i have i have uh let up on
taco bell i've took taking my foot off
the gas
and don't go easy on me because i'm in a
bad way today
i wouldn't insult you like that all
right thank you
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you all right ready
yes
okay kfc i've let off the guests with
taco bell i i frequent in taco bee uh in
college as a younger uh chap
now it's like for me it's like uh
emergency food or one time on tour in
the uk the last time i had it was on
tour in the uk three years ago and we
were drunk and nothing was open and we
all did a pilgrimage to taco bell and i
ate it and it's it's it's decent going
in but it's not good after that everyone
knows that they have a stigma with them
it's for a reason
what's the stigma there's a like a bowel
movement statement yeah that you run i
honestly swear to god running for the
border oh
uh you know
one of the first stand-up jokes i ever
wrote
what taco bell make a run for the
[ __ ]
well so you you told me you didn't know
that i made that up and i felt like it
was my own idea
i guess it's not
so um and then i also think i recently
read
an article that ranked fast food spots
and the quality of their ingredients
particularly their proteins and i think
taco bell
was low on that list i don't want to
disparage taco bell right because i i i
love their cinnamon crisps i love that
seven layer burrito i mean i i'll tell
you this concept
but you know taco bell is so delicious
that mexican pizza uh you i have my
dairy issues you know there are dairy
things like certain dairy products i
can't have certain cheeses
uh certain milks whatever
one of the things that doesn't get me a
little upset to less of a degree than
say mozzarella cheese
is sour cream
i will mussel through it i love sour
cream i will mussel through it for taco
bell because that's get that hot sauce
packets oh god dude so i will actually
make my mouth and inner ear itch
so i can eat a taco bell supreme has
there ever been someone who has gone to
taco bell
what percentage of people you think that
have gone to taco bell and had a healthy
serving did not have
a bowel movement that was very left of
center
hours later
well i mean you're talking as if you're
you're you're you're skipping through
the daisies after kfc i mean no but it's
not as it's not as uh
combustible i i would say that you you
would you would potentially battle a
different animal on the toilet after kfc
i would say that the constipash
can come into full effect really why so
uh because of the amount of
weird fake dairy products you're
ingesting in their behavior whatever
those mashed potatoes are made out of
i'm glad you brought it also i think the
sodium has an effect the sodium puts me
in a sodium you don't think in that taco
meat this is a bunch of sodas it's
nothing it listen kfc is delicious for a
reason that is as high in sodium as you
are ever going to get food i'll tell you
right now i l there's there's a room
about kfc remember the rumor that they
couldn't call it because it used to be
called kentucky fried chicken for you
young ants it is again though they
changed it back the kentucky fried
chicken yeah uh and they said that they
couldn't call it it because the
usda or something like that said that it
didn't constitute real chicken or
something like that i think that was a
big uh
uh wives tale
yeah that was that was never true that
was you know like but i got the colonel
here's okay i got the colonel
secret recipe that's a good kfc is
there's a recipe that is on the lock and
key from the dawn of kfc that they will
not give out that proprietary
information is golden i got the colonel
backing me up
just a southern gent
on your end you got a chihuahua
walks around a party hat might have died
might have died two decades
i got news for you the colonel's dead
he's got look at this for a chihuahua
you know he's dead right now he lives on
in all of us
the chihuahua looks like for chihuahua
he looks like he has gigantism in that
headphone he's a cute kid he looks like
he has a large brain he's a cute kid but
i'm telling you something i'm telling
you something my two favorite foods on
planet earth we've discussed before are
fried chicken
and homemade taco kit yeah
kf's i mean taco bell is the only place
you are getting homemade taco kit style
tacos anytime i go to a restaurant i
order the hard shells it's a
disappointment anytime i go to an
authentic taqueria and i order the hard
shells i like them but it is nothing
like that home kit you go to talk taco
bell has its own kit
you can go get a taco bell kit in the
store and make your own taco bell at
home how do you uh how do you find the
consistency across the platforms
do you feel like the taco bell at home
is is hitting the same solution in the
same nail that on the head that the uh
that the brick and mortar talk about
honestly
i love it but no
and here's why
there is and we've we've argued this
before
i appreciate a certain quality drop in
my fast food when i make it at home it
tastes too quality
there's something about their
whatever that paste is that they call
meat
[Laughter]
that is delicious and it makes it what
it is it just makes it what it is you
know what i mean they i'm not sitting
there do you think i'm dicing those
tomatoes the way they dice them no you
think i'm shredding lettuce what are you
nuts no
you should though you could just hit it
up real quick with the knife it's not
the same though it's not the same
but taco bell like not even just
at home not even a bathroom i just get
sharp pains i think i don't it's always
delicious but i mean it's right away
that it's not good after you finish look
kfc's not a little bit this is fast food
okay we're talking fast food fast food
is what it is it's fast food so it's not
like it's going to be some michelin [ __ ]
but let's just let's just run to the
menu of kfc
all right let's see yeah no this is for
you this is just been pulled up a lot of
good facts so i want to go back to even
the
way they were founded what year they
came out of that stuff too but uh will
taco bell upset my stomach uh how common
is food poisoning from taco bell it is
believed that at least 150 people in 21
states have suffered salmonella
poisoning after eating at taco bell
restaurants and at least one food
poisoning lawsuit has already been filed
against the mexican fast food chain that
was in 2010. i'm sure you i'm sure you
i'm sure that's across all fast food
though i don't wanna yeah now google
yeah kfc uh
uh food poisoning did you put is taco
bell diarrhea real is that what that
just said yeah yeah is it real well
family abc news the sydney family has
won a case against fast food giant kfc
after same thing salmonella most
commonly reported symptoms from ksc is
poisoning and diarrhea we're not here
this is not a hit piece
we want to make this clear
a hit piss
this isn't a hit piss or a hit piece on
taco bell or casserole just one in the
gamut from from praise to so to what we
hear negative we're doing this because
we
we actually like these products how am i
not getting taco bell tonight after
looking at these pictures look i got you
know how a lot of times you guys buddies
the taste buddies the listeners they
always say like after listening they had
to go get it this is gonna be one of
those episodes it's gonna be a kfc taco
bell night tonight i bet you hey
corporate at kfc and taco bell uh
november 22nd check your files and see
if you got a spike tonight in sales
yeah maybe they start trending online
too by the way same owners pepsi owns
both no [ __ ] yeah that's what you've
never seen a taco bell in kfc under the
same roof no i thought that was a pizza
hut pizza on pizza too babe wait what's
that song you know that song i'm at the
pizza hut i'm at the taco bell i'm at
the combination pizza and taco bell
never heard it
never heard it it was a hit for a minute
never heard it pimp i'm at the pizza hut
taco bell we'll definitely get ripped
no i don't like this i like the other
one i'm at the combination pizza hut and
taco bell
i like the other one better i mean this
is cool this is a pimp's alley i feel
like yeah
this was like a song that wasn't
like people took it seriously like it
was on the radio yeah yeah i know
but i'm saying
all right
listen
under the same roof
all right owned by the same company
pepsi who also owns pizza hut
there is nothing better and i'm going to
say i'm going to sing praise to both
sides of this
i my buddy jim lives in atlanta
when i get off the plane every time
first stop for us is the combination
pizza taco bell in his neighborhood we
get a little of both and we go to town
dude you gotta go on two lines for that
no it's one line all one reg
one reg
one person giving it to you one reg
under god
i i will say this
look i love again we're not here today
let's bury it can i can i hit or yeah
can i take you on a little like tour of
the taco bell menu i mean the kfc menu
yeah you're telling me what are you
putting what are you pulling from taco
bell's menu that's gonna go up against
an original three-piece
with a mashing grave
and a biscuit
never even mine can take a walk no
never even i tell them i'm not even
going to be i'm not even going to get
into the coleslaw on the mac and cheese
i'm not even going to get into it i tell
them don't give me the biscuits first of
all you're you're a lunatic their
biscuits are lunacy it's the one thing i
hate at kfc because i think they're like
hockey pucks okay popeyes now we're
talking biscuits but we're not here to
discuss pop-ups love that chicken pop
pies
coleslaw banger kfc a gravy mashed
potato banger
i thought you were going to say that it
was no good no do you know that do you
know that those are the banks this is a
true thing in my life that's the sonny
and share of the sides true thing in my
life this is god's honest god's honest
whether i believe in god is a different
story
i'm listening
so that's a lot to unpack
ksc's mashed potatoes
are my favorite mashed potatoes i've
ever had in my entire life that's an
insane statement i like them they might
even be instant i like instant potatoes
listen i don't mind instant potatoes you
eat those things without the gravy it's
a it's a nightmare no they have harsh
they have a flavor that nobody else can
achieve it is so goddamn good i dumped
that gravy in there and you're you're
you're i think you're giving me a pound
something no
you take the gravy out of the equation
those potatoes are a nightmare and they
serve them with the option of no gravy
which means some people like them on
their own
the gravy i'll give it to you but you if
you got home and you didn't have that
gravy you would hate every bite of those
things and you know i'm telling you i
love it to pieces it's my favorite but
you said you dumped that gravy in there
no but i use the gravy but if i don't
have gravy i still love it i eat it with
gravy though that's right i love it
buddy well guess what it's a good thing
because the gravy's on the menu when it
comes with it so i don't have to worry
about eating it dry right right and the
original rest let's talk about it let's
talk about the original rest
okay because i believe it's the same
thing with like coca-cola these these
companies that where they like the like
the the like the ceo and the founder
have they're the only two that know it
and it's like in a safe somewhere and
it's under lock and key that's real [ __ ]
so i'm telling you that original rest i
got it in a recipe book at home binging
with babish has done it he did it he's
got a youtube video yeah and he shows
you how to do it yep
i'm guaranteeing you it's not coming out
the scene now he told he he he told me
he says on the video with the secret he
said so this is how only derozan is he
thinks the guys on the tv are talking to
him
by the way that that bob saga party he
just watched a doc no i'm like i'm like
the cable guy he saw norman leah talking
to cameron he was like my friend norman
leah told me
no no he says in the video what the
secret ingredient is because i've i've
got a recipe book where i've tried to
put together the combo and it's there's
something missing every time but bishop
the chicken skin a [ __ ] wait hold on
let me push
msg
he's like that's the thing that's in
there that's making it like really
special madison square garden yeah
the greatest venue in all the land yeah
yeah yeah it's in kfc
they're doing big things speaking of
which do you ever go to the kfc in the
basement of madison the one with the pen
yeah yeah
those are some i've i've gone there i'm
hands-on
i'm hands-off at underground food
establishments they're hands-off it's
some dark days down there yeah it's some
dark days yeah but listen go ahead
originally it feels weird to me
especially when you go like down down a
hallway that not a lot of people oh it
feels like human rats
down there to me yeah all right so let
me talk to you buddy
about canva pro all right i know camera
probably have a pro the design platform
that empowers you to create and share
stunning content in just a few clicks
i've designed things in the past i've
had to hire people to design things in
the past i am not a designer i have
friends that are designers but what i'm
trying to get at is canva pro is making
design amazingly fast and fun and i
think it allows people who aren't
schooled in the field to also to be able
to do this for themselves i i started
using it because i like to make the
content promo so you can use it for the
website socials anything like that yeah
yeah and then it's also a great tool for
actual designers too uh thousands of
templates are available endless premium
fonts there's photos there's videos that
you're allowed to use because they're
licensed uh and you can add all kinds of
to that that's a big deal though
the images are licensed too so you don't
have to go and buy
images yeah yeah i actually use it to
edit the no press shows yeah yeah so
there you go we added our stuff with it
uh there you go that's putting your
money where your mouth is right and you
could do it together uh
they let you share edit and comment in
real time so you can work with someone
and not even be in the same room with
them canvas pro helps you stay organized
on the same page and on top of team
projects uh you can work uh with four
teammates if you want or up to four i
guess uh and you can unlock everything
canva pro has to offer for just 12.99
a month with canva pro's content planner
you'll see that you'll you're going to
save time planning and creating and
posting social media content all the
stuff we just said it's true and we got
a guy here that actually uses it yeah
and my fav stuff is the uh the royalty
free options that endless options they
have photos because even for the show
when we're doing practical jokers we
have to purchase anything that we put on
there and it's always like a hassle you
have to like it's just it's just
annoying it's an extra step i mean dude
we're designing stuff for the bar and
it's like you know you you want to pull
pictures and you want to have you know
colorful things yeah and you know when
references or whatever canva pro
makes that stuff a lot easier and a lot
more positive design like a pro with
canva pro right now you can get a free
45-day extended trial when you use our
promo code just go to
canva.me slash taste buds to get your
free 45 day extended trial that's c a n
v a
dot m e
slash taste buds canva dot me slash
taste buds baby babies let's talk amazon
musees buddy buddies
just cause that's this show not the
other show that you're on
but that's in my vernacular i know i'm
kidding i know i say babe i i'd say it
all i can't stop saying i know anyway
amazon
music let's talk about it more than 10
million free podcast episodes including
hey babe and taste buds yeah that you
can listen to uh you can listen to our
hilarious podcast uh amongst many others
smartless is on there uh what else is on
there dr death is on that's not a
hilarious one dr death miracle man is a
true crime one but the point is there's
all kinds of podcasts and you can listen
to them but it's not just for podcast
listening they have thousands of music
stations playlists that you can stream
for free and no matter what you're
listening to you can go hands-free with
alexa
oh i hope she didn't hear me is she
gonna be that was one time remember we
were doing this and she heard you yeah
sometimes alexa just chime in god love
her if you like me and you want your
music on demand and ad-free you had to
try amazon music unlimited which gives
you access to over 75 million songs
which i don't think you could get
through this week yeah uh i like that
they have levels of this that you can do
i think that's really cool some music
services it's like it's this or nothing
you know yeah i like that they have
levels of this where they're like maybe
you don't want to spend money maybe you
don't want to spend a lot of money maybe
you do and or you want to spend a little
extra to get the full i i think that's i
think that's cool when a streaming
service of any kind allows you to do
that
i like using it like when i'm gonna like
uh take a shower and do some self-care
where i know i'm gonna do uh i'm gonna
put on a toner i'm gonna put on some
maybe some moisturizer maybe clip on my
nails that day i might be like truman
the beard i throw on a station i like on
amazon music and i let that baby roll
amazon music unlimited because it's
different because some other stations
you don't have skips like you can skip
but then you have to listen to some of
them sure this is unlimited skips so i
do it when i know i'm going to have a
real hum dinger in the bathroom okay all
right fair enough look if you've never
tried amazon music unlimited now's the
time for a limited time new customers
can try amazon music unlimited free for
three months you can't beat that there's
no credit card required just go to
amazon.com taste buds
amazon.com tastebuds you're going to get
amazon music unlimited free for three
months amazon.com
taste buds renews automatically cancel
kfc was founded by colonel harlan
sanders
focus finish with the original recipe
thing you were going to say you
literally in the last three minutes have
said skin recipe
don't finish your thoughts i want to
hear it i think that
fine you want to discount biscuits the
the two staples are bangers the chicken
the fried chicken and the mashed
potatoes the fried chicken is on another
level i mean talk to me about well i
want you i want you to take an item off
the taco bell menu to put up against the
kfc original recipe
chicken listen you make a great point as
i said i haven't even gotten favorite i
haven't even gotten
i haven't
i haven't even broached extra crispy all
right oh i haven't even broached you
haven't and don't bother broaching it
it's a waste of my time it's flavorless
extra crispy is flavorless keep getting
it keep getting in the sub basement at
penn station
i am telling you something i've had
times in my life where i've eaten kfc on
a weekly basis i'm not exaggerating
you ever have a bowl a kfc bowl i
wouldn't waste my time
uh but i'm telling you something i'm
telling you something i
never
get original recipe once a year i'll go
i'm sorry uh i never get extra crispy no
i go rich i go original because the
original christmas a year i'll go you
know what let me get extra crispy again
i i'm i'm in the mood and i get it and i
go this sucks it's just not as good
popeyes no are you sure you're not
getting the tenders because sometimes
people go in there and they try to get
the tattoos i actually like it i'm
talking about the actual fries tenders
actually have good flavor no the tenders
are way more like original rest oh look
at that look at that
also you know how you said one time
extra crispy is weak their mac and
cheese sucks the mac and cheese their
mac and cheese needs a refresh the green
beans whatever what are we talking about
didn't know they sold them all right
the corn is surprisingly quality fine
for fast food corn snap is a snack but
when you go to kfc
what you're really dealing with is
original recipes let's talk about their
fries
with the flour on them
they taste like
those are underrated fries in the fast
food game nobody brings up kfc's fries
and they deserve what about their the
wedges the potato wedges they were good
too dope but i will tell you this this
is the point i'm driving at kfc's got
one trick and one trick only what's that
original recipe because the seasoning on
the fries is original recipe seasoning
the gravy that the mashed potatoes
desperately needs tastes alive kind of
like original recipe and then you got
coleslaw all right that's what you're
dealing with
you're taking a menu of items and
calling it a one trick pony you're
saying it's one one trick they got one
trick yeah they do they go okay well if
that's their one trick
call them david copperfield because
they're amazing told me was msg all
right
you want to talk about they got papayas
you want to talk a banger
you want to talk a banger yeah what what
do you got what is griffin what is evan
with the doritos loco taco have you ever
had that thing
i haven't i haven't
i haven't but i don't know if i like
allowing doritos into this argument bro
the doritos loco taco is a menu item
that thing is insane taco bell has a
steak and potato taco
that will knock you sideways
all right with a cheese sauce on it do
you ever have a chicken uh chicken
roller from taco bell never heard of it
melted cheese chicken and chipotle sauce
it'll change your life i used to get a
seven-layer burrito when i was in
college when i was delivering pizza i
would go through the drive through the
seven layer burrito weighed about a
pound and a half a dollar nineteen yeah
i know that's good value but i will tell
you the staple food from a taco bell if
you have to choose one is an original
classic taco by the way let's take that
let's take that all right let me take
one piece
drumstick breasts whatever you want to
do of original recipe chicken put that
piece of original recipe fried chicken
up against that original
beef taco from taco bell
who comes out on top
i think a supreme taco from taco bell
comes out on top okay i'm i think it can
absolutely contend
but as i said i'm at a disadvantage here
kfc is my most frequented fast food i
cannot in good conscience knock the
beauty of original recipe but what i can
do is argue that taco bell is a better
spot because there is a much more
versatile menu a much
better place
by nature
it's like a laboratory for mexican food
over there they're doing crazy
by nature of it being mexicano food by
the way there's [ __ ] four ingredients
they jumble it together they call it a
different thing every time
unless you go to taco bell when they
actually do something called
doritos fries where they had a doritos
cheese sauce you can dip your fries in
i'm glad i'm glad i'm glad that doritos
is putting taco bell on its shoulders
for you but there's that famous gaffing
a bit and it's true it's like
the mexican food is five things and they
just are gonna hit you here at devil and
cold i'm gonna hit you with i'm gonna
hit you with something that kfc does not
have and that nobody's ever said about
kfc okay and then it has only been said
about taco bell okay
fourth meal they they marketed this
to americans they marketed fourth meal
as if you shouldn't be ashamed that
you're adding a meal
what do
taco bell no what are they called a meal
it's breakfast lunch dinner
taco bell they're saying his fourth meal
because so many people have to get it
late night
and people proudly still
still went and did it that's saying
something about the food they're
basically saying hey slobs
come
get an extra dinner
i mean the kfc bowl is the whole menu
like great that's their kfc bowl is the
whole menu throwing a bowl uh are you
one of the great ways of all the time is
the pat not as well as well right uh
oswald patton oswalt good good bit with
that the case you all um remember the
other day a couple battles ago you were
like it's so great because peanut items
come in a bag and there's something
about getting a bag or something you
said yes well let me take that lodge and
apply it to
a bucket
because there's not many times where you
can order food in a bucket
bucket full of food i see and ksc is the
king is the granddaddy king of food and
buckets
you come home with a family a family
bucket you're providing for your whole
family i see your bucket yeah i see your
bucket i see it and i raise you
the taco box
is that a thing yes they got a tin taco
box
it's called a taco box i ate an entire
one in my car when i was 18 years old
once while i was driving i ate 10 tacos
out of a taco pimpy pull up the taco box
for me
you're still working some of that off
yeah exactly look at this dude they got
a burrito with it they put a hash brown
in for christ's sakes they're flailing
though that's why i'm not flailing i
don't think that's i don't think that's
inventive i think they're like we got to
do something we got to do something to
shake this up the dog died and we need
something throw a potato in there that's
what i think they do no no i think
they're like genius have you ever had a
hash brown with taco it's one of the
most delicious things you're ever going
to eat in your life
look at that thing dude
taco and burrito cravings pack a pack
dude
that's that's that's a pack
it's only three three a bucket no you
can get ten taco boxes it's still on
their their uh grub hub menu look at
that look at that fried chicken sandwich
on the top right from kfc i didn't even
delve into their sandwiches i didn't
delve into the pot pies
they had desserts look at the chocolate
chip cookie i'm going to hit you with
dude you're not effing with you're not
after the chocolate chip butter cake
baby you're going to put a kfc chocolate
bundt cake against the chorizo are you
nuts or not the cherry the chalupa
what's no no you cinnamon sticks bro
that's what you have cinnamon they're
okay no cinnamon sticks look at these
cinnabon delights they got little mini
is that new right is that new it's been
three years not that no
no what is that what's that twist oh
that's gotta that's gotta
no on their menu it's called cinnamon
twist in real life isn't it called a
cholula churro churro that's right yeah
but that no but that's not what that is
because that's not baked did you ever
have this thing do you ever have the do
you ever have the uh chalu what is it
called the the the chalupa that's
another thing you guys are just making
up names at this point it's like a
gabagipa
it's amazing but did you ever have the
chalupa the bread on that thing tastes
like it tastes like they put it tastes
like they wrapped funnel cake around a
taco it's amazing i'll just i'll just go
back to it again because it's worth it
it has merit i'm just saying their
website has sodium warnings oh my god
the deluxe cravings box and the my
cravings box has a literal triangle
warning on it that says look out
this is too much sodium and that's that
they didn't choose to do that that came
down from an authoritative branch and
babe people are still going in droves i
understand
that's wild
this is enough sodium for a week
that's the thing you're dealing with
here
let me just say a gordita a chalupa a
taco a burrito a fajita a mexican pizza
every single one is lettuce tomato
cheese sour cream couple beans chips not
true at all it's the same [ __ ] that's
not true but if you want to get into the
same [ __ ] different different day
uh somebody uh somebody named abysmal
said taco bell equals hiroshima [ __ ]
so i'm all set on that don't you don't
you love a cur
wait colonel's steering the ship he's
got a southern drawl if you want to he
walks with it
he's got a handlebar mustache
yeah he's probably a filthy racist let's
be honest no you know what i think he's
probably got problems don't project he's
probably
here's what i'm saying
you want to talk same same dog different
fur
okay like you are about kfc
taco or about taco bell kfc is doing the
same thing they're taking their one kind
of chicken
and they shove it into a bun or they put
it in a box or they throw it into a bowl
it's the same it's there come on fair
thank you very much baja blast
exists so oh god are you nuts by the way
baja is not a thing no no she's she's
not talking about baja fresh i think
she's saying there's a menu item on taco
bell called the baja black sorry i'm
sorry okay all right let's go to the
phones where are we at pimpy we gotta
wait an hour okay okay let's go to the
phones all right dusty williams says the
only reason i would go to kfc is to [ __ ]
the only reason i would go to kfc is to
[ __ ] in a bucket after i have talked
about i mean that might be the winner
right now that's like that's uh that's
he should be he or she should be a
politician uh what else we got here taco
bell has so many options kfc is just
chicken i'd rather do popeyes for
chicken fair point uh a hard shell taco
from taco bell is just wet dog food a
handful of chopped lettuce three pieces
of chopped tomato and an overwhelming
amount of sour cream i don't agree with
that but that's fair
uh both very good but i feel taco bell
has better variety aha kfc is for
special occasions that means they put it
on a pedestal taco bell is when it's 3am
and i desperately need eight different
combinations of the same five
ingredients all right but but many other
people have said taco bell is beating
kfc in the in the versatility game oh
yeah what am i saying bro uh yours is
taco bell is your order to make a run
for the border or yokiedo taco bell
i got i what i got finger licking good
it's finger licking
bring that up till now i certainly
wasn't going to mention i blanked oh you
really see kfc is the first post-divorce
meal you eat on the floor
taco bell is not no that's so true
that's every every look uh what am i
thinking that i didn't bring this up
every movie or tv show where they're
depicting a man that's out on his ass
and that was like is sitting there with
a bucket of chicken
every time well taco bell is the food of
the drunks right i mean look how good is
food to be where you're licking your
flesh after you eat it to get remnants
of that delicious
that's been their slogan since i since
before i was born and i've loved kfc for
my whole life i've never once licked my
fingers that's disgusting
nobody does it it just sounds good you
eat it and you go like no no i don't do
that i mean my hands are washed i don't
do that what am i garbage i don't
who licks their fingers while they eat
that's gross what are you garbage
you're funny you you you you bite a
combo but you throw the whole reese's in
your mouth and i'm crazy
[Laughter]
uh taco bell all day every day you can
get chicken anywhere
but at doritos
thank you that's what i said
depending on my mood i usually choose
the cat food they consider beef at taco
bell over the bootleg thanksgiving meals
kfc office i want to give the win to the
divorced lady give me a famous bowl in
the chicken little and keep it moving
i'm with you
all right the divorce lady all right the
the the worst on the apartment floor
meal i think that's the [ __ ] that's
actually just
okay
the guy [ __ ] in the bucket almost had it
do we let's give two oh that's good too
that's good at steph noll you can follow
her at s-t-e-f i'm sorry
s-t-e-p-h-k-n-o-l-l
and then also
we have a tie today it might also be
step
canal the uh also follow dusty williams
the only reason i go to kfc is [ __ ] in a
bucket after i have talked about at
dusty
sorry
at
there you go
uh at dusty
0 wi-204 5 5 9 5 4. dusty you could have
done better with that one buddy all
right let's see who won
and wrap drum roll it's humble pie time
pimp throw up throw up the percentages
we got 11 000 votes not too bad pimp's
choosing taco
wow finally
god i've been getting the crap kicked
out redemption
58.3 goes to taco bell for the win i had
a feeling taco bell was gonna take it
because i feel like it's more of a
lifestyle choice for people it's more of
a uni it's more of a universal you're
getting a you're getting a whole um
a whole uh
cuisine
at taco bell versus just
chicken which is like well but uh but
also too i i there's a surprising i'm
surprised at how few people i know when
i say kfc they scoff
okay because it got such a bad rap after
certain items got released and then also
how many people i know that when i say
kfc they go come on dude popeyes
taco bell's got no comp unless you're in
la and they got a del taco i mean but
you know how close you can i will say
i've never had popeyes
but i i doubt it's better than kfc it's
not but popeyes is great yeah so when
somebody says they prefer that's what
everybody's talking about everybody was
beating each other up for that sandwich
a couple years ago right yes popeyes
taste like if k if extra crispy was
better okay
and that's that that's all they got they
got this they got you know this was it
wasn't a blowout it was admirable win
though 58.3 to 41.7 i took that l
i took that bell
but i still love you babe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds